Hello, this is a video on the internet.
You last saw us playing
golf with apples and-
We we're awesome.
We were damn amazing.
It hit me in the head.
Today we're doing
something a bit different,
the Happy Gilmore.
If you don't know what that is,
then where are were you in
the nineties, pretty much.
It was a quality film, amazing film.
Who's up first then?
Yeah, me I think.
Is this a putter, is it?
Yeah, it's a, it's a putting wedge
that you use in the sand and water.
In the sand and water?
Yep.
Okay.
I'll go first then.
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, go for it.
Do it again.
Hang on, let me get that.
Are you gonna show me how it's done?
Yeah.
Gotta get that in slow mo.
I kept that.
That's brilliant.
Practice one, all right I'm ready.
hell.
Jesus.
Was that good?
Yeah, only just landed.
I don't think I've hit such
a good drive in my life.
That was like the best drive ever.
Well there we go.
I thought those were some
pretty damn impressive
Happy Gilmores to be honest.
Incredible techers there.
You hit an incredible drive.
It went so far.
I hit it to the next field.
It's the best drive I've
ever hit in my life,
and it was a Happy Gilmore.
I think I was like, I hit it, I was like,
that has gone miles.
I went for,
I did a slightly longer run up,
and I ended up with just a lot of ground.
I think half the turf went with my ball.
Yeah, you tried to take
the garden with you,
that's what it was.
Well, there we go, job done.
See you in the next video.